1 et le tallec rare aux besoins tête de
20 ans l'attendrait arrive plus fort
qu'un coup de baby loup
j'arrive plus fort qu'un coup de maillet
bululu ans de rim vous et tout ce boulot
c'est ouais ouais chine est donné en
fait mon métier ça a été beau c est en
fait et vous souhaitez crypte
oui ça doit pas la lâcher
mais pour l'instant le meilleur je vous
le dis c'est jean mi saison mais au
dessus du lot mais maxime justement
c'est parce que je comprends je
comprends et images and you n'ont pas
besoin qu'on fasse des caisses j'achete
plus devant qu'un ouragan
ouais ça me fait rire je le confesse
appelle-moi benji l'odorant vieux way